اتون من الحجاز وغيرها عبر طريق ابا القد
المعروف بالجديه وصلت قبائل عربيه ومنها
بنو حنيفه الى قارات الحبل فكانت الخطوات
الاولى للوصول والاستقرار فيما بعد في قلب
حجر اليمامه كان ذلك قبل نحو الف وستمائه
عام بقياده عبيد بن ثعلبه زعيم قبيله بني
حنيفه هو الذي انتقل بقبيلته من الترحل
الى الاستقرار في وادي العرض
بمرور الايام استبدل الوادي اسمه القديم
ليكون مراه لاهله فاصبح كما يعرف
وادي حنيفه
الجم القاره والحبل المعروف ما تنبته
السمره والطلحه والسياله
والسلمه زي اللوبيا طيب هذه القارات شمال
الرياض الان طريق الملك سلمان يخترقها هي
من الحجر الجيري دوائر صغيره منتشره
وسيد بني حنيفه منين جاء وليش اول ما نزل
نزل قارات الحبل قبل ما ينحدر جنوبا الى
حجر اليمامه وياخذ الحدائق المتبقيه من
طسم وجديس هو لابد في النطاق الجغرافي عند
النزول من ايضا الحجاز بني حنيفه لانه
نزحوا من الحجاز
ونزحوا لعوامل مختلفه لكن المؤرخون يشيرون
الى تتبع مواقع القطر يعني في ازمه حصلت
في تهامه عشان نقول هم جابني حنيفه جو من
المدينه ولجوا من مكه ولا من تهامه جبال
الحجاز
الانتقالهم هنا ووصلوا ايضا الى
الجديه وبيعدم ومن الجديه ايضا اتجاههم
هنا الى الشرق وايضا الملقا ثم نزحوا ايضا
والى هذه المنطقه الواسعه المسماه بقارات
الحبى العباره عباره عن قاره هذا الجبل
الماثل امامنا احد ايضا القارات الموجوده
ولهذا كانت
كان هنا النزول والاستقرار اياما متعدده
ثم نزوحهم الى حجر اليمامه واستقرارهم هنا
ولهذا كان ابعد نقطه مكانيه بين حجر
اليمامه وبين قارات الحبل في الناحيه
المكانيه ولهذا يقول الشاعر القديم من بني
حنيفه او الذي سكن في حجر اليمامه يقول ما
ابالي الايم سبني ام عوذئب بقارات الحبل
هنا الذئب تعوي الذئاب هنا لانها بعيده عن
المكان الاصلي في حجر اليمامه فهناك
المسافه الشاسعه ضربت العشرين كيلا الان
اصبحت المسافه قريبه بين حجر اليمامه
وقارات الحبل فتلاحمت
وتلاقيت ايضا هذا المكانين المعروفين
والذين كان لهم من الاهميه في تاريخ
الرياضه
اذا قارات الحبل نزلوا هنا عبيد بن ثعلب
الحنفي اكيد كان معهم خيام ما بناوا ولا
وكان في موارد مياه قديمه صحيح لكن لما
راح الراعي جنوبا واكتشف في قصور في حجر
اليمامه وحصون نزل ولهذا
الابار القديمه وايضا بعض الشعبان القديمه
تاتي هنا من الجهه الشرقيه في المطار
القديم والمطار القديم حتى عباره عن اثار
قديمه تعود الى 20 الف سنه في المنطقه
كلها ملعه ايضا بالاثار القديمه وايضا
تعود الى الاف السنين طيب خلنا ننحدر الان
جنوبا الحجر اليمامه من قارات الحفر نمشي
على نفس الخطا اللي مشى عليها عبيد بن
ثعلبه الحنب
[موسيقى]